-Our next guest is the mayor
of New York City!
Please welcome to the show
Mayor Eric Adams.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you for finding the time,
Mr. Mayor!
-Thank you, thank you.
It's good to be here.
I'm normally up late at night,
leaving Zero Bond,
watching your show
before hanging out, you know.
-I don't know
when you're sleeping,
because you are making
the rounds of this great city,
and I think that's why people
are drawn to your term so far.
How are you finding it
in the early days?
-This is an amazing place,
resilient.
You know,
never bet against New York.
We --
-I think that's a very --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-We come back.
We come back stronger,
better than ever.
You know, we went through
through a difficult period
during COVID,
but when you are out,
and New York is --
We're just ready.
The way goes New York
goes America.
The way goes America
goes the globe.
It starts here in New York City.
-Well, that's very exciting.
Are you reaching out
to any of the people
who've held the job previously?
-Yes, all the time.
You know, Mayor Bloomberg,
who is a good friend,
Mayor de Blasio, but also mayors
through the city.
Mayor Suarez and I,
we're good friends.
We're competitive.
I'm saying to all those
New Yorkers who went to Miami...
get your butt back to New York.
This is your city.
-I think, you know, ultimately,
they're realizing
they made a mistake
when they went down to Florida.
It's not New York City.
-Listen.
You can only have so much sun.
You can only ride
up and down that beach
every once in a while.
New York, we have it all.
-Yeah, we have it all.
Now, maybe you can answer
a question for me.
When does a person
officially become a New Yorker?
How long do you
have to live here?
-Probably a combination.
When you could
get on the subway station
and you get a seat
before anyone else,
when you can navigate that,
I think that is --
From day one, when you come
to New York and realize
the power of our diversity,
that's our secret weapon.
And if you are comfortable
in any neighborhood,
you could walk into
a Chinese restaurant,
have a Russian cook make you
an Italian dish that he learned
from his Romanian girlfriend --
only in New York.
-Only in New York City
do you get all those things.
You mentioned the subway.
I will say, you know, obviously,
this is a difficult time
for the subway.
There's homelessness.
There are mental-health issues.
I will also say
that I was very happy to see
you and the governor addressing
this as a problem together.
We've obviously gone through
a tough period of time
where the governor
and the mayor of this city
did not get along
particularly well.
Do you feel bullish about
the future of the subway system?
Do you think
that you can make a change?
And how do you deal
with the homelessness
that is plaguing
the subway system
in a way that's humane?
-A combination.
When I started
my law-enforcement career,
I was a Transit police officer
during the '80s.
We rode alone,
without a radio that operated.
It was something where you saw
graffiti everywhere,
crime, drugs.
And we made that transformation.
We could do it again.
But we have to do it
in a humane way.
The subway system is a microcosm
of the pain people are feeling,
and if we go down there
and just displace them
without dealing with their pain,
then we are just kicking the can
down the road.
We have a comprehensive plan
that is going to put people
in housing,
deal with
their mental-health issues,
but also set the standard.
You can't be on the train
shooting up drugs,
pushing people on the tracks,
committing crimes, barbecuing.
No, this is
our transportation system!
-Yeah.
-And so we want to send
the right message
that people should feel safe.
That's the lifeblood
of our city.
If it's not safe --
It's the great equalizer,
no matter how much you make.
You could be from Wall Street
or live on my street,
you take the subway system.
We're all the same,
and I want a good, safe, clean,
affordable, reliable
subway system.
And I'm going to give that
to New Yorkers.
-I think that's something
we could use.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two things I believe to be true.
I believe this is
the greatest city in the world.
I hope I live here forever.
I believe there's way too much
garbage on the street.
-Yes, yes.
-How does that --
You know,
there are obviously a lot
of other cities in this country
that have large populations,
not this big,
that do not have that problem.
-You know, and you're right.
And so what I have the team
doing, we're creating
what we call an emerging-market
innovation hub in our city.
And we want to go
all over the globe
and find out what are people
doing differently.
So my goal is,
there's some places,
like Buenos Aires and others,
where they're not putting
garbage on the street.
They put it into bins
at the end of corners
so we could have clean streets.
So we want to do things
differently.
I don't want to think
outside the box.
I want to destroy the darn box.
New York is supposed to
lead the way.
And garbage is one way.
We don't want the rodents.
I'm scared as hell
of those rats.
-Yeah. This is a very --
You're really facing your fears
by taking on this job, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So we want to deal with
the garbage on the street.
The perception of filth,
of the street homelessness.
We don't feel safe
in our city anymore,
and trash plays a role in that.
Cleanliness
is next to Godliness.
-That's what I keep hearing,
and I think you're right
on that.
You're gonna be facing
some protesters
on the steps
of City Hall tomorrow.
-Yes.
-Some LGBTQ organizations
are upset with
three appointments you made.
These are people who have said
some pretty hateful things
about gay people in the past.
They've apologized.
Their apologies did coincide
with their appointments.
And how do you --
What do you say to a community?
And I should also note,
you've always been out in front.
You have a great record on this.
So, what do you say to people
who were disappointed
by those appointments?
-This is such an important and
significant moment for our city,
because -- you're right --
when you look at the record
of making the important vote
for marriage, gender --
even as a police captain
standing with members
of the LGBTQ-plus community.
And so here we are.
When I voted for marriage,
my brother-in-law told me,
"You can never come back
in my church again."
He later apologized for it
because, you know,
he knew he was wrong,
and I spoke with him.
We must move
from the cancel culture
to the consultation culture.
We have to take people --
Don't meet them where they are.
See them where they are --
Or, I should say,
meet them where they are
and take them
where they ought to be.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-All of these --
You know, people romanticize
now about marriage.
But go back there
and look what America was.
President Obama
was against marriage.
Many of our elected officials
were against marriage.
So when I was standing
on the Senate floor,
saying that, no,
people have the right
to marry the people they love,
no matter
what their gender may be,
there were a lot of people
in America and New York
who demonized folks like me.
Now they came along.
We should be in a position
of converting people
to be at the right place,
'cause we got more battles
ahead of us.
You know,
marriage was just one of them.
And so I'm saying to the members
of the LGBT community,
you're talking about Eric Adams.
We fought together to get here.
So you have
the right to protest.
You're gonna come
inside City Hall
and sit down and speak with me,
and we're gonna talk.
But we're gonna go out there
and show people
that we need to be
with those who are transgenders,
because even
the transgenders believe
that members of the community
have been mean to them.
We're going to convert people
to be who we ought to be,
not who they have been,
and that's what I'm going to do.
-Well, I wish you
all the luck with that
because I think that is
an important journey.
You, um -- I want to end
by remarking on the fact
you're a very clean eater,
even though this is a hard city
to eat clean in.
You're a vegan.
You eat a little fish.
-No, I'm a plant-based eater.
You know,
I want to keep my body tight.
I got great abs.
I have a nice firm behind.
-Everybody was saying that.
-I want to stay that way.
You did a press conference
recently
with a smoothie you drink
every day,
and people remarked at the fact
this did not look like
a delicious smoothie.
[ Laughter ]
How did it taste, Mayor?
And be honest.
-Listen, first of all,
don't look at the way
that it looks.
Blueberries are inside there,
cacao powder,
matcha powder, spinach, kale.
That's how I start my day,
every day.
-Alright.
-You know, and we want people
to enjoy --
The fountain of youth
is in your food.
And if you eat right,
you're going to look right
and you're going to be right
to yourself and to others.
-Alright, well, you know what?
I can't think of a better place
to leave it than that.
Hey, thank you very much.
That's Mayor Eric Adams,
everybody.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."